primary elections yesterday progressive
Democratic candidates say they are
optimistic about the outcome of key
primary elections held just yesterday
hundreds of thousands of people voted in
New York and Kentucky where there were
long lines of cars outside many polling
places now we may not know the results
for days because the pandemic caused a
surge in absentee and mail-in ballots ed
O'Keefe is covering campaign 2020 for us
Edie good morning so we don't know the
results what do we know what we learn
well what we learn Tony is that election
nights in America are quickly turning
into election weeks as we await those
kinds of results and as we do wait it
looks like two New York City congressmen
who lead key House committees are
fighting for their political lives and
one closely watched race educator Jamal
Bowman currently leads 16 term incoming
eliot engel the chairman of the House
Foreign Affairs Committee Bowman has
surged in recent weeks thanks in part to
the increased attention on racial
justice nationwide meanwhile
congresswoman carolyn Maloney who
represents part of Manhattan she leads
the House Oversight Committee and holds
just a narrow lead over Suraj Patel a
younger liberal opponent that she
defeated back in 2018 in Kentucky the
Democratic Senate primary remains a
toss-up between moderate Amy McGrath and
liberal state representative Charles
Booker who also surged in recent weeks
thanks to increased focus on the case of
Brianna Taylor in Louisville they're
competing to take on Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell in November and
the primaries were held on the same day
that former President Barack Obama and
former Vice President Joe Biden held
their first joint fundraiser during the
event mr. Obama warned Democrats not to
take the election for granted and
criticized President Trump we can't be
complacent or smug or sense that somehow
it's so obvious that this president
hasn't done a good job because he won
once and in one life we didn't have a
good clue as to how he was going to
operate the last time
the Biden campaign says it raised about
11 million dollars last night that it
that's its best one-day haul Gail there
are just 132 days left until Election
Day but who's counting a toki who's
counting we're all paying attention
thank you always good to see you mr.
Okita